How to increase progesterone production in women with normal LH,
that's the Dynosine Hormone, FSH,
follicle-stimulating hormone,
and E3G levels currently at a healthy weight and take chestberry
and earthlys nourish herdaturaly and earthlys fertile boost.
Okay, so I don't sell those products,
so I would literally have to Google them and see what's in them.
So if you're trying to increase progesterone production,
my question is, would be why in the first place,
what are you trying to do, did you measure it?
So if the person answered yes, I measured it.
I did a horrible profile in my progesterone is low.
And I read I have all these symptoms of low progesterone,
or I'm trying to get pregnant, that could be an issue.
A person can have a difficulty getting pregnant
because they have low progesterone,
or they've lost babies,
and they're trying to be able to hold a pregnancy,
it can be because of low progesterone.
It's fairly easy if you know those things,
and you're trying to then boost progesterone levels up.
It's fairly easy to do so
because there's a lot of topical progesterone on the market.
So I don't know those products that you just mentioned in the question,
whether they have progesterone in them.
If they're oral products,
I mean, you're taking a pill,
or they're a powder or something like that,
then that probably doesn't have the progesterone.
So the progesterone that you could buy on the market is a serum or a cream.
And you put it on your belly or your thigh,
and you absorb that,
and it works wonders to boost your progesterone.
So that's the easiest thing to raise,
really, from a hormonal standpoint, is progesterone.
You can, like, oh, I don't want to take hormones,
I don't want to take any progesterone.
You can just stimulate through adaptogens,
and I would assume that that's what these products
that you mentioned are some adaptogens.
So taking those, if you haven't started those or you just started taking them
and then measure your progesterone again,
that would be the thing to do.
If it's still low, then you could probably go with the serum topical.